It is 57 degrees in New York City in
January,
coffee on a Tuesday and blog,
46 in the deep reaches of our universe
and starless spaces as here in New York
City.
Time passes without impediment like a
ball rolling smoothly downhill forever.
We are,
as humans drawn to extrapolate it
forward and backward to the coffee we're
meant to get with a friend later this
afternoon to the siege of Constantinople
in 12.
Oh,
four.
To our illustrious future of flying cars
or to the time when you tried to teach
her sister to cal when she was three
out loud.
Our meditations take us far before and
far beyond the present moment so far.
We feel the gaps like giant,
deep breaths in our hearts.
But was there a time when time was.
What I mean to say is,
did time ever begin?
Let's start with the Wilkinson microwave
and a Satrapi probe.
Board w map a measuring device launched
far into the solar system in 2001 to
take spherical images of the universe at
several different frequencies.
We've observed the first light emitted
in our universe.
Some 380,000
years after the big bang.
It's called the cosmic microwave
background.
Though we can't see before that we can
extrapolate using the speed of the
expanding galaxy backwards to determine
that the big bang happened around 13
point 7 billion years ago.
We can,
however,
get to the moment of the Big Bang,
we can only probe with our physics two
right after to a second,
after to a millisecond after to one unit
of plank time,
roughly 10 to the negative 43 seconds
after the big bang.
Many of our brightest believed that the
moment we can't see the moment of the
big bang is in fact a singularity and
infinitely hot and infinitely dense
point,
which when released,
created space and time.
Others disagree saying that our universe
is merely one in a series or part of an
infinite loop of expansion and
contraction,
but are we any closer to conceiving of
an answer to our question?
As the oed defines it,
time as the indefinite continued
progress of events in scientific terms,
it's the perpetual transition from low
entropy to high entropy from a ordered
state to a confused one.
You can crack an egg,
but you cannot uncrack it.
You can remember the past,
but not the future.
The truth is that the only reason we
know time is there is because we
perceive it.
We don't see it.
We see simply causes and effects and
conclude its presence as St Augustine
said,
what then is time?
If no one asks me,
I know what it is.
If I wished to explain it to him who
asks,
I do not know.
So where are we?
Just confused.
Mouthpieces asking absurd questions
like,
when did time begin?
The question won't even allow itself to
be asked.
Why?
Why is it unreachable?
Well,
maybe there's an answer in the
beginning.
The Big Bang.
The singularity is essentially a
discontinuity,
a break in our understanding there
wasn't,
and then there was the concept of
emergent phenomena is extremely
important.
It's something that arises as the effect
of complex causes,
but is not analyzable simply as the sum
of their effects.
A great example of emergent phenomena is
Darwinian evolution.
The formula that is natural selection
can be arrived at simply by studying the
laws of physics.
Indeed before Darwin.
That's what every biologist tried to do.
It was Darwin's genius to see that the
rule of evolution emerged from the rule
of physics,
which is to say,
given the initial conditions of the
universe,
one could not predict the emergence and
rule of Darwinian evolution on earth.
There is a discontinuity between the two
sets of rules in the same way.
There's a discontinuity between matter
and light from the particles of matter
emerge,
the organizing principle of life
compatible with matter,
but not analyzable as the sum of its
effects,
and here is where time comes back into
the picture.
Matter by its very definition is a
function of space.
It can move through time,
but taking generally is not effected by
with the emergence of life space and
time,
converged life is the evolving
complexity of an organism in every stage
of its evolution corresponds with a
moment in time and vice versa.
Now,
there's one more emergent phenomena in
this sequence and it's the most
important to both us and our discussion
here.
The emergence of the mind.
As life came from matter,
the mind came from life,
from the increasing complexity and
growth of the brain coupled with of all
things the vocal cords.
It was at the dawn of language probably
sometime in the last hundred thousand
years when the dual emergence of symbols
and the mind changed everything again,
the use of language to make symbols
which are just names that change in
different context allowed for the
creation of a symbolic reality.
In other words,
everything you see around you,
the rule of symbolic reality is again,
compatible with life but not analyzable
as the sum of its effects.
It's something new.
Our minds are something new,
whereas matter is a function of space
and life is a function of both space and
time.
Our minds,
the human mind is purely a function of
time.
Think about it.
What is the one evident quality of
thoughts that they have to happen in
sequence?
The only way we can tell one idea from
another is by identifying the order in
which they occur.
This is why it's hard actually
impossible for us to fully wrap our
minds around time or to consider a state
in which it doesn't exist.
You can't use a ruler to measure the
absence of space in a very real way.
What we consider to be ourselves is
composed of time stuff,
and it is given to us of all creatures
to consider,
measure,
conserve,
and extrapolate it as we wish.
We are each of us time superheroes.
Wow.